what do you think of ramanajan
a self-taught math genius
this is just i'm just overwhelmed by it
because he he did something that
you know i thought would have been
almost impossible that that he managed
by his own unaided efforts to turn
himself into one of the
you know greatest mathematicians i mean
you you look at what he was
growing up in he was he was growing up
in extreme
poverty and i mean even
surviving in those conditions would have
been as much as most people could do and
to
to do this phenomenal mathematics i just
cannot imagine how he did it um
i mean you know i mean ramanujan himself
said that you know how did he get his
mathematical formulas and he said he got
them in dreams from some goddess or
something and
i i can't actually think of it a better
explanation i mean
it's it's it's almost miraculous that he
managed to do this
right some of the formulas are so arcane
and so esoteric
that you wonder how can you come up with
it without deriving them and he would
just
they would just pop into his head and
they would turn out to be true well
i i don't know i i think i think he was
fudging a bit then i i think it was
um i mean you know some mathematicians
have this a bit of a desire to keep
their methods to themselves a bit
and maybe maybe romantic was doing that
to some extent
um but i i really don't know i mean i've
looked at his
some of his papers and books and i just
i just cannot imagine how he thought of
them i mean
some of his formulas you can prove by
using techniques that ramanujan didn't
know about i mean
it's kind of notorious that manager
never knew complex analysis
which is a but he know and which is a
very powerful method for
evaluating integrals but somehow he he
never seemed to feel the lack of it he
was able to do by
real variable methods what most of us
need complex variable methods to do
so somehow he just got
really really really good at real
variable methods in a way that almost
nobody since has managed to equal